Uh, Donald Trump is trying to go after the
Hispanic vote.
Increasingly, we know that he has said he
loves his African Americans as he has pointed
to people in the crowd.
By the way, the guy he referred to is my African
American.
He, I guess is no longer a Republican.
So that didn't go super well.
And Donald Trump now trying to appeal to Hispanic
and Latino voters.
Trump did a campaign rally yesterday in New
Mexico.
The idea was let's show up there and let's
talk about how low Hispanic unemployment is
and how great everything is.
And it went about as poorly as you would expect.
First of all, bad poll after bad poll for
Donald Trump in some key swing states for
2028 years of tax returns subpoenaed, as I
already told you about new corruption investigation
into Trump's transportation secretary who
happens to be Mitch McConnell's wife, Elaine
Chao.
So Trump in the midst of all this shows up
in New Mexico and tries to appeal to Hispanic
voters, sort of in the same way that he tried
to appeal to black voters in 2016 which is
blaming other people for things and citing
incorrect statistics.
The clips are genuinely hard to watch, but
also kind of fun.
Listen to Trump here as he talks about the
Hispanics as he refers to them.
Bye.
So where the Hispanic American, the Hispanics
were up with me in a poll, 17% and everyone
said, how was that?
How was that?
How was that 17 up by 70% I won't even tell
you what the final number was cause they won't
believe it, but you're going to see what the
final number.
But you know why?
Because the Hispanic Americans, they understand
they don't want criminals coming across the
border.
They don't want people taking their jobs.
They want to have that security and they want
the wall.
They want the wall
taking their jobs.
It's truly hilarious that they still use that
stupid debunked, bogus talking point meant
to completely exculpate big corporations from
the immigration, low wage status quo that
persists here in the United States.
And more importantly, the bigger lie there,
Donald Trump claiming that Hispanics want
the border wall.
It's like, no, they don't.
Most of the country doesn't want the border
wall.
And if you're looking specifically at Hispanic
voters, they, we, I should say as part of
that group, we don't want the border wall.
I mean completely and totally untrue.
Trump also heckled.
Yesterday, a bunch of times I was only able
in the time I had to prep this morning, I
was only able to pull one clip where you hear
the heckling going on Trump doing all the
normal, a of a attempt to attempt to appeal
to Hispanic voters.
You'll hear him getting heckled after the
initial applause line here in the background.
Trump, uh, just continues talking over it
and actually does successfully
yesterday marked the beginning of the Hispanic
heritage month.
Who is Hispanic here?
[inaudible]
Latinos for Trump.
oh, we have much to celebrate.
Unbelievable.
When you think the unemployment for Hispanic
Americans is right now at the lowest level
ever recorded in the history of our country.
[inaudible]
Hispanic American poverty reached a brand
new all time low in history,
[inaudible]
and after years of stagnation that you know
very well, wages for Hispanic Americans are
rising really fast, up nearly 8% since my
election.
Those are unheard of numbers,
[inaudible]
and medium income.
Think of that median income for Hispanic Americans
surpass $50,000 for the first time ever.
So
this is the same type of pandering that we've
seen from Donald Trump before.
Yes, the polls don't look good among Hispanics
for Donald Trump or in these swing states,
but the only poll that matters in the end
is how people actually go and vote in November
of 2020 if they actually choose to vote.
So despite all this pandering, despite all
this rambling and all of it, that man that
you just saw talking about Hispanics and lying
about the wall, he can still win in 2020 on
autopilot.
If we do not show up how a Hispanic voter,
speaking as a Hispanic voter myself, uh, can
support Donald Trump at this point.
I don't know.
And the rallies make it even more confusing,
patronizing, marginalized and minority communities
in the most obviously transparent ways.
The supporters are totally cringeworthy.
It's an international embarrassment and it
actually in the end may all work to get the
guy reelected.
That's just the, the sole focus needs to be,
no matter how cartoonish the clips I play
for you, no matter how unbelievable and erratic
and, and bogus are the claims that Donald
Trump makes, he can get reelected in 2020
and he can do it even if his approval rating
drops 10 points mathematically.
That is, uh, and so in the end, all that matters
is that we actually go and vote in November
of 2020 and get as many people as possible
to go and do the same thing.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
And while you are there, follow me on Instagram
at David Dot.
Pacman.
We'll take a quick break and back with all
of her thorn
from philosophy to right after this